в той день Я казала мамі що ну щось буде
недобре сьогоднішній день Бо з самого
ранку і дуже часто повітряні тривоги
А ви тоді У цей день 14-го числа Як не
дивно ми будували плани на півроку
вперед був просто дивовижний настрій
мені ну іди вже відпочивати це буквально
на хвилин 10 було коли я
відклала телефон поруч з собою лягла
закуталася щоб засинати вже і я просто я
почула якийсь гуркіт
виключили свет вимкнули світло вимкнули
інтернет і чоловік мене кличе в сусідню
кімнату Ми беремо ковдру накриваємось і
Буквально за 10 хвилин сталося те що
сталося
[музика]
через цю фотографію Анастасію іноді
впізнають на вулиці вона одна з тих хто
вижив після прильоту у житловий будинок
у Дніпрі 14 січня це останні фото що
залишилися з
моїм котом залишками моєї квартири коли
ти дивишся і розумієш що все було добре
в тебе була сім'я в тебе був будинок
Насті 24 роки вона жила разом з мамою
татом і котом на вулиці набережна
Перемоги Коли російська ракета влучила В
їхній будинок дівчина була у спальній
кімнаті а батьки на кухні я просто
дивлюся у сторону свого коридору і
розумію що бачу сусідні під'їзд а
ніяк не можемо його бачити з квартири і
я розумію що ну
в будинку більше немає Я розумію що мої
батьки на той момент були на кухні разом
Я починаю їх кричати звати і розумію що
кухні взагалі немає у суботу це
трапилося і десь по обіді У неділю я вже
дізналася що батьків знайшли їх дістали
з-під Завалів і вони загибли разом
у вересні торік Настя пережила ще одну
втрату під час контернаступу на
Харківщині загинув її хлопець Владислав
який пішов воювати добровольцем Це був
дуже жахливі для мене дні тижня Бо я
взагалі я не вставала з постілі я нічого
не їла Я ни з ким не розмовляла
мати майже заново Вчила мене ходити бо я
не хотіла не вставати не з ліжка нічого
Для мене життя на той момент закінчилось
і наразі Мені здається може
тому що знаю як вже переживати цю втрату
Мені трохи легше переживати втрату
батьків тому що я ще не змирилась з цією
втратою і тут вже має батьків
після трагедії Настя живе у родичів має
відпустку за лікарняним незабаром хоче
повернутися на роботу у пекарню дівчині
досі лячно від повітряних тривог
доводиться приймати заспокійливе але
вона впевнена що життя триває Якщо зараз
впаду депресію якщо
я буду лежати ридати кожного дня Ну
життя від цього ніяк не зміниться
на дні Мені важко болять Я розумію що
Треба рухатися далі Я розумію що якщо
мені даровано друге життя і другий день
народження то я для чого щось тут ще
потрібно і я повинна продовжувати жити
тепер не тільки для себе і за себе а й
продовжуєте життя за своїх батьків Я
буду рости Я буду розвиватися і Буду
намагатися щоб їх життя і їх справи були
недаремні
із психологом Ольгою яка жила в тому ж
будинку ми зустрічаємося неподалік її
нового житла квартиру Ользі і її
чоловіку надали незнайомі люди люди
також лінія що люди Таке враження що
об'єдналися всі у велику суперсилу і цю
суперсилу як wi-fi передавали нам усе що
в мене зараз є в нашій сім'ї це все дали
люди і одяг і фінансова допомога і
підтримка і квартира це відео Ольга
встигла зняти одразу після ракетного
удару у її квартирі на дев'ятому поверсі
вціліла лише спальня де саме відпочивали
вони з чоловіком Євгеном жінка отримала
травму голови Але чоловік вчасно зупинив
кровотечу і подавав сигнали ліхтариком з
вікна аби рятувальники швидше його
помітили для Ольги і Євгена це не перше
випробування у 2014 році вони виїхали з
Донецька до Херсона навесні торік
довелося залишити і це окуповане
росіянами місто поэтому наша сім'я яка
обнуляється тому наша сім'я обнуляється
уже втретє починає життя спочатку
найдивовижніше 14 січня був наш другий
день народження я це вважаю нашим другом
днем народження
15 числа нам дзвонять сусіди з нашого
будинку який у Херсоні там зовсім
небагато людей залишилося На жаль через
ситуацію і прилітає ще одна новина у
нашу квартиру в Наш будинок в Херсоні
теж прилетіла ракета
тому що сказати
таке життя але у нас є можливість жити є
ми а матеріальне думаю з часом прийде
якщо ви ще сили дали нам шанс залишитися
живими вдвох
і цей шанс жити то я не маю жодного
морального права опускати руки зрошувати
подушку слізьми і це мені дає Стимул
жити далі Я розумію що кожен день це
велике диво життя це диво і кожен день
це можливість іти далі І жити і вона в
мене є на відміну від людей які
перебували в цьому будинку Які так само
будували плани які Ростили дітей
планували життя на довгі роки
на долгие годы это ця можливість є у
мене і я думаю що правильно не втрачати
цю можливість і
не опускать это возможность
[музика]